MAA shaker has spotted her daughter
she's been released from an Israeli
prison and will soon get off this bus to
Freedom after a little search among the
crowds she finds
her then they hug like they haven't in a
long time the 24-year-old was detained
in October last year held without a
charge her detention was supposed to end
in late October the war put that on
hold prison is by default a difficult
place as we lose our freedom but after
October 7th the prisons became much more
difficult we couldn't get our basic
needs as women and as humans the tap
water tastes like chlorine we used to
buy bottled water but even that became
off limits for us her cmate El B had
been in prison for over 2 years she
hadn't been sentenced yet and like many
other Palestinians could have remained
behind bars for a long
time we've been beaten up We've Ended a
phase of total isolation we lived in
Exile we left a
graveyard most of those released on
Friday are women others are teenage
boys families from across the occupied
West Bank waited outside Aur military
prison in ramala for this
moment raan abuad had 8 months left on
her sentence some of the scenes here are
moving Palestinians meeting their family
members the father of raan told us that
he spent eight years without being
allowed to visit her many of people here
are celebrating but they say that their
celebrations are shy because they
remember those who have been killed in
Gaza since the war six Palestinian
prisoners have died in Israeli
[Music]
jails I was released naked in my boxes
without a phone or anything we've been
tortured in jail we heard difficult
cries from other sections especially
prisoners from Gaza and so a lot of
blood Muhammad's brother kusai was named
as one of the 39 Palestinians to be
released however he had already
completed his sentence and was freed on
Thursday his cousin Ahmed had a month
left on his one-year sentence but was
released as a part of the
deal it's a Bittersweet moment why did
my name make it to the list when I
finished my sentence my cousin Ahmed
it's good that he's out but there are
other people who have 15 or 30 years
left some are boys though should have
had
priority even so this is a moment
to cherish a needed break fam say from
their ongoing pain nid ibraim Al jaaz
the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler